and this is technically not a game from
of the week this was played uh
uh quite a bit quite a bit later
but uh it was played when was this
played actually it was played i want to
say
you know maybe a month ago or so i i've
already lost dates and it's really funny
because i i was saving some notes that i
uh
so the the the date on the game is
actually wrong
but it was something like this and uh it
was a really really cool game
i think it was about a month ago though
and this was between greece shook and
mbl
and i really enjoyed going over this so
i would say that um
how would i put this like one of the
favorite things i like to do when a
tournament is going on like a really
major tournament
is i try to follow the games and i try
to
figure things out as best i can as i go
it's one of my favorite things to do
when i um
when i when a big tournament's going on
and i try to figure it
follow it on on my own and try to figure
out what the players are up to
and i kind of wanted to do that with you
i'll show you some analysis and stuff
like that but i also kind of want to
show
how i go over these games myself because
i'm trying to learn from them and i
would say that
i could show you okay this is probably
the best here this is what i checked out
um but in a lot of ways i much prefer to
kind of go over them
organically and so this is how i learn
from these games and this is how maybe
you guys can try to learn from them too
so this was grishok mbl this was
one of the later rounds round 11 i
believe
so e4 so
grishok tries to throw off mvl's dragon
ah not dragon geez knight of mbl plays
the nether for every game so this is how
g
shook a lot of modern players like this
d4 line
and the idea looks really weird but the
point is that
you take with the queen excuse me on d4
draw back to d2 and the whole point is
that you're actually going to just fee
and shadow and castle
and at first when i look at this
position i'm like i don't understand
why can't you just play bishop g7 net f6
castles castles but then after f3 i
looked at this position and i was
studying this with my study partner gm
steven zirk who's actually also been
um he's also been
a
gm in residence here quite recently so
he was definitely
uh and we went over this together and he
was convincing me that man this position
is just horrible
because the problem is for black that
this bishop on b2 is actually quite a
good piece it defends the king
and it's really hard for white black to
ever attack if you try to play a5
i play a4 if you try to play a6 b5 i can
just ignore you
and my idea is just to play h4h5 and
start attacking
and it turns out that this
is really really just annoying
and really difficult to play so
so in the game though mvl plays the move
bishop h6 and now i really understand
this move because
if you don't play this it's just very
unpleasant
those positions are actually quite
annoying to play for the black side
so his idea here is to actually throw
off white's coordination
because white doesn't want to play queen
d1 then at the very least you could just
play back so for example if queen d1
you can play a move like bishop d7 and
at least to my mind this is a whole
tempo right and a whole tempo means a
lot
for example after queen d2 you could
even think about taking right
and then if knight takes e4 then there's
bishop takes b2 something like this
all right um
so then that so the whole tempo really
matters a lot so maybe you could try
queen d3
but now i can probably take on c1 rook
takes and now i feel like
the b3 moves kind of wasted the rook on
c1 is weird
you can just play knight f6 and just
castle and the exchange of bishops isn't
that bad
so i feel like these moves always throw
white off
so the idea is that white plays f4 and
keep in mind i don't know this opening
myself like i've never really played
this for either side
so i don't know much about it i just
know that this is what i went over
when i went over with steven and he knew
a little bit more about it than i did
so he explained some of these things but
a lot of it was me just trying to figure
out the position
so when i saw this i'm like wait bishop
h6 why would you play bishop a6 when you
could just play bishop g7
and then it was after looking at that
position playing it out with my study
partner after f3 i realized wait this
position is actually really unpleasant
um so knight f6
is what was
played
in the game and now bishop b2 and the
whole point now is that because you've
been forced into f4
your structure is just not as stable
with the pawn on f3
it's more passive but it also is very
solid and then this idea is just really
really good right
but once again if black does just castle
castles a5 you can play a4 you're not
really doing that much
so even though the pawns on f4 i can
play here i can play like
h4 later maybe it's a little bit
unpleasant maybe
so in the game he played e5 right away
trying to put pressure on f4
and one of the things with mvl is he's
very predictable
but he's also very sharp which means
that he will not be afraid to play the
challenging lines against you i think a
lot of players
they're faced with the novelty they play
very safe
and one of mvl's strengths and
weaknesses in my opinion is that he will
not he will play
what he believes is best he trusts in
his calculation to figure this stuff out
and i'm not saying that he was i think
at this point he was still in theory but
he does not shy away from these kind of
locations at all
so it either works out really well or
works out really badly
so grishok plays knight g2 and you could
tell he's still in prep here
which is unsurprising they're both under
10 moves so castles castles bishop e6
king to b1 you want to get off this
diagonal at some point
so mvl tries a4 a5 a4
so at first i was wondering does it
really pay for black to do this
like to lock up the queen side like this
but then i realized the problem is that
the alternative is to try to play like
a6 and b5 and this is just so slow
and does so little right and then you
have to worry about this pawn hanging
too
so i realized after a little bit that
playing a6 b5 just doesn't help you
enough
so i think that the idea of a5 a4 is
that now
you've kind of reserved this square for
the night where it can be kind of
annoying hitting the c2 pawn
you have queen b6 ideas which is what he
plays
and then this position also was very
very tricky to understand
so grishok played the move h4 and once
again i think he's probably in prep here
or at the very least
sort of new or actually no i think h4 we
looked it up later h4 was a movie you
spent a lot of time on
and it's a very aggressive move but at
first i'm like is it necessary like can
white just play h3
and what do you guys think can white
just play h3 my idea is simply to play
d5 next
and i'm banking on the fact that taking
here is almost always going to be ugly
because you're opening up my bishop on
this very
strong diagonal
so that's a good question after a5 how
do we react to queen d6
i think the issue with queen d6 is that
your like your queen side and your
pieces are a little bit unfortunate here
so
maybe the best way to react is actually
just to take stuff
so maybe it just takes
and now maybe takes here
it looks weird but the point is i can
open up the lung diagonal without queens
right like opening up the long diagonal
is not as big a deal
and one of the issues i think white has
here is that this knight is actually
very
very bad because it blocks this bishop
on f1
and you're also having to deal with
these knight g4 ideas which could be
very annoying
so i don't know because like you could
play knight d5 it looks nice and
aggressive but maybe knight takes pawn
and i do want to show something really
clever here which is that rook takes c6
looks very strong at first
because if i take the rook then this is
believe it or not mate
don't fall for that poison girls but you
can take this knight and i think that
this position is actually very very poor
uh for white because whites down a pawn
but also this knight on e2 is just quite
bad
right it's just a really bad piece
because it blocks all your guys
so i think this position is actually
quite problematic
um so i don't know i don't think i would
i would grab that guy
um on d6 but that's why he doesn't take
right because
i think that he needs it to be a middle
game because as long as it's a middle
game taking the f4 pawn is just going to
be kind of suicidal right
so like if you try taking on f4 here for
example and i played knight d5 this
looks just atrocious right like look at
this guy
on open diagonal you could try to take
this pawn but
i don't know i would be horribly
terrified here
um i'm not even so sure you have to play
knight d5 immediately by the way maybe
that's even a misnomer but
i'm wondering yeah hopefully i didn't
lead you astray with that
conclusion but yeah this maybe is not so
clear i guess because if queen d3 my
idea is that on here i can go here but i
don't know
oops no that that move is not great i'm
oh goodness what did i do
all right yeah but i don't know
this is a little bit fishy maybe you can
even just take this knight and play
knight f2
okay this was a bit too too ambitious
guys knight d5 is too much but you don't
have to actually take right away
uh you could play knight takes f4 even i
i don't think you get
killed by this pin
so i'm wondering here like yeah i mean
this the problem is having this bishop
open is just really really strong
i think after he takes f4 so he takes f4
in the middle game is not going to be
quite as strong
right but in the end game it becomes a
really annoying move
so in the game he played queen b6 so
trying to play very very aggressively
and i think justified
um so he brings this queen out
but yeah this h4 move so i guess my
first question though is what happens if
we just play h3 we just kind of play
more conservatively
because this is kind of what i wanted to
do at first
but once again steven definitely had a
better grasp of this than i do like he
plays a lot more sicilians for both
colors like he play
he's played some for black but mostly
not as much but he's played a lot of it
for white
um and i haven't i played a lot of
sicilians for white but that was over 10
years ago so
his feel for this business was better
and one of the advantages i would say of
having a study partner
is that there'll be positions which i'll
feel better than him and ones where
he'll get it more than i will
and having a study partner will help you
with that so if you have a study partner
you can look at these games with it's so
valuable
because i learned a lot just from
looking this position over with him and
playing lines out
because i thought that h3 followed by g4
looked very strong
but he convinced me otherwise the
question is what idea did he convince me
was very good here
so why don't you find the idea that he
found which is very very good for black
okay
so bishop g7 h5 i think is quite slow so
if this move for instance and i play g4
i'm ready to play f5 already right and
this is going to be very strong
um of course you could take on f4 or
maybe you should but after knight takes
f4 i feel like white's position is quite
good here no
because i control d5 very well my pieces
are all harmonious
knight d4 i think i can also take this
um
so say actually i don't know
so if the knight takes
yeah i'm actually not so sure maybe this
end game is decent but it's hard to say
so it takes
hmm what to do here
maybe knight here is actually kind of
clever now
i don't know if this is necessary by the
way but the idea of my of mine is that
after
after uh if knight takes here you can
simply take the queen right
um so that's not gonna work so you have
to try to take this knight
but if you take with the pawn i thought
i could even throw in bishop takes g4
and maybe not maybe i just take back i
don't know
and the idea now is if you go for
something like this again the long
diagonal is very very good for white i
believe
and if you try knight e4 i can still
play queen takes
pawn i think and you have to take this
queen and then
maybe even rook takes you have knight f2
and knight g3 but i think i can move my
rook like even this looks very ugly but
i go here and
i think white's just kind of up upon
here it's still not completely clear of
course
but i don't know probably i would take
white because the bishop can move next
it's not like i'm stuck for the rest of
the game or anything
so i don't know but black has a very
very sicilian-esque idea i would say
here
and very very effective so rather than
try to use play knight d4 or use the
pieces you have try to improve and get
in pieces that you don't have yet
maybe but again i i don't think he wants
to the thing is this knight is a really
bad piece
and i think it's very important that
black realizes this and doesn't try to
improve it
very good khan ah so rook 88 and the
whole idea is that now of g4
you play d5 and the whole point is that
if you try to play g5 now
i played knight takes d5 with tempo and
the same goes with other tries right
like this is just all with tempo
so this just doesn't work out for black
and this idea is actually just very very
strong
oops right because if you try to play
like
if you try to take the pawn or do stuff
like this you're just opening up all my
guys
and this is actually quite bad for
white i think so it's imperative
for griez that he played very quickly
here and i think that he appreciated
this more than anyone
um so he played h4
and h4 is a really really nice idea and
this was a position where i think that
mvl played a bit too casually
so grishok's idea of playing h5 is a
very very potentially powerful one
so for example here playing rook 88 is
still possible
i believe but it's not nearly as clear
because i think i play h5 and the
problem is taking on g6
is a huge threat and the main point is
that i get rid of this annoying pin on
the pawn as well
and if you try to play knight takes pawn
now you're not threatening d5 at all
right
so even moves like knight d5 become
playable but i have also other options
with this right i can play g3 which is
kind of similar idea to what he did in
the game
but mainly it's just knight takes h5
destabilizes him
um and if you play d5
and allow h takes g i think that your
position falls apart because
even if you play knight takes pawn your
bishop on h7 hangs all the time right
so you could do any number of things
here the simplest is probably just
taking this just to get rid of this pawn
uh and pin the bishop and i think this
is already just a huge disaster right
so this is not something you'd want to
do so h5 this idea of playing for h4h5
it seems like it's in every game now is
especially strong here
the question is what should mvl do i
think his move was a bit lackadaisical a
bit lazy
which again doesn't seem like him right
but he does play very quickly and kind
of by hand a lot
and i would say that this particular
position it's so important to play
concretely
and he's usually a very concrete player
which is why i'm surprised but i think
that
the move he played in the game was a bit
too casual
so what should black do here what do you
think the best idea is against h4
and this is something i analyzed very
long time with stephen and it's
immensely complicated
um so it's not easy but what do you guys
think black should do
yeah again knight d4 i'm not so sure
about i think that it's going to
encounter some of the same problems we
did before
it's black's move here so
in the game he played rook ac8 which is
a nice looking improving move but i
think is also
not not the best
i think black has to be very very
ambitious here the question is with what
move
so i've seen knight d4 mentioned a lot
but again i i feel like this is gonna
backfire on you somehow like you're
you're not really
wanting to take to like again you're
trying to trade off the c2 knight which
is black's worst piece that's kind of
the issue with i have with this move
so say if knight takes pawn pawn takes
there are just too many options here
that probably should be okay for black
for white so say not exactly
sure maybe i'm underestimating this too
it's very possible
it wouldn't be the first time but even
as even a move like knight b5
knight takes and then like queenie one
something silly and the idea is d4 hangs
next at any point i play knight xd4 i
play
g3 like white's position is now
very nice all my pieces make sense
everything is kind of okay
so i i just really i don't like
fixing this piece this piece is so bad
and when i see a piece like this i just
don't want to assist it in any possible
way
which means i don't want to play any d4
i don't want to play e-d-e-f
and yes you have to play concretely but
i'd say you can still follow general
rules which is that if your opponent
has a piece like this that is just
jamming their whole position
you do not try to free it for them you
make them free at themselves
and i'd say this is a good rule of thumb
that you guys can follow because it's
just
again every like every rule in chess
it's like 60 90 right like
i would the rule i give is that
nothing's true not almost nothing is
true more than 90
of the time unless it's like a queen is
better than a pun right or a knight
something like this but even there it's
like never a hundred so
you know you never assume a rule is 100
but
when you get think of a rule you think
okay between 60
and like 90 and i'd say like this is
like an 80 ish
85 percentage rule where it's like your
opponent has a piece that's really this
bad you just don't try to fix it ever
like just leave it be
but white does have a threat of h5 so
you have to deal with h5 in some fashion
um
so the correct move though is very
aggressive like black tries to make
threats of his own
he doesn't try to to do anything
remember though the knight only two
like it's already kind of bad right you
don't have to make it worse so bishop g4
is
interesting but it also doesn't i'm not
so sure it actually helps
your cause also i'm not so sure i can't
take this pawn now because your knight
now hangs right
so maybe i could just get away with
taking this and this would be probably
not good
so that's something i definitely don't
like
queen f2 is interesting but again like
the night's already kind of paralyzed
and terrible you don't really have to
further the cause queen f2 is very
tempting though i will admit
i think the issue is that white maybe
just ignores you and plays h5
and claims you're not doing anything so
something like queen f2
maybe i can play h5 and just ignore
and again i don't know that this is that
bad but
because you could play knight takes h5
maybe now i play maybe night here
centralize my pieces
i don't know
yeah but keep in mind with ef like i'm
not necessarily gonna take right i'll
probably play queen c3 at some point
so again i'm not saying queen f2 is a
bad move it definitely looks really
interesting
but um i don't know i i just
i'd be kind of worried about our king
side a little bit here
knight g4 to f2 yeah
so knight g4 oops knight g4 i think is
the best try
so the idea is that knight f2 is coming
and it is
actually a big problem so knight t5 is
an interesting try here
but i think the issue is after bishop
takes pawn takes knight e7
we didn't really find a great follow-up
but again it's the stupid knight on e2
is just really bad
so if you try h5 here for example i
think you could just play knight f2 and
take the rook on h1
and if rookie won you can play knight f5
queen e3 and this is just kind of tough
because takes and you take with
something maybe this night i don't know
and this night again it's just so bad it
is such a horrible horrible piece
so this is actually just a very big
problem
so h5 is kind of what i wanted to do but
even here it's not so easy net f2
and i can't let you take the h1 rook
because that's my best piece so i was
looking for ways to play like
i was trying to play like rook h2 which
looks
very very odd right
uh but the idea is that i'm trying to
get in hg so after knight takes knight
i really want to play h6g but the
problem is after takes takes
say knight take c3 bishop takes f4 is
very good
so i have to try queen takes c3 and then
queen f2 here i think was annoying um
because i have to play rook h1 but this
is not a good sign like if i have to
play this passively
so i really wanted to make the rook sack
work but i don't think it does so i
think
the best try i came up with was maybe
knight takes d1
and the idea is that after bishop back i
have f5
because here h takes g is a huge threat
black has to improve the bishop
so f5 takes takes and then queen g5 i
think was my idea
um and i don't know i thought that it
was at least
interesting but black does have bishop c
king c2 knight rook c8 we were looking
at this
and i don't know it's just immensely
complicated
it is very complicated but again the
fact that this knight on e2 is just so
bad
continues to haunt white here so i don't
know exactly what we
determined was best and again like a
computer might know right away but for a
human being this is nearly impossible
but as you can see knight g4 is what
presents white with immediate problems
and is probably the best point
so he played rook c8 which looks safe
enough but the problem is now h5 and all
of a sudden he's in some trouble
so 1965 and this idea of g3 is really
really sweet
so his point is that he's actually not
in a rush to attack he wants to play
bishop h3 and complete his development
and claim that his 992 is not so bad
after all
and the whole point is that once you
open up this h file
the bishop on h6 is quite bad the knight
on h5 is quite bad and it's just really
an annoying position to play
so just really really instructive play
so he plays knight b4
and now just bishop h3
and all of a sudden it's actually really
tricky because if you allow this capture
your pawn structure is actually really
bad
even for the end game it's terrible it's
just not solid so he takes
but now he's given up this d5 square
potentially as well
which could be a big problem so he plays
bishop back to g7
and here once again grishok i think
comes up with the most accurate way to
play
and i would say accuracy is so crucial
in these positions because even if
it's very promising one little lazy move
as we saw and it could change the whole
evaluation
so you want to make sure you're playing
in the most accurate way when you have a
position this sharp
because there are some positions you can
play slowly and it's correct especially
when it's a slower position but you have
a position like this
well again he's going to try to play for
d5 eventually right playing for d5
opening up the center trying to
attack the c2 pawn black has ideas like
if you play too slowly eventually
something will happen
so it's very important that white got in
bishop h3 to trade off that bishop
and now the problem is it's really hard
for black to get counter play but at the
same time black will eventually get cut
or play probably
maybe doubling even on the c file try to
put pressure on those knights
queen f2 is still in the mix i would say
so i don't think there's no pressure
here or anything like that
but you uh you want to be accurate
so what would you do here is white
so f5 followed by g4 is one idea
i don't hate it but it's a bit slower
than the way you played
very good khan g4 and this is his whole
concept that he doesn't want to give
black room to breathe he wants to
basically suffocate black as soon as he
can and this move is very accurate
because if you try taking an f4
i played knight takes f4 takes and now
again i have different options on how to
do this i would say
uh i think though the simplest is
probably just queen h2 i wanted or maybe
just
rook h1 is the simplest
and the idea is that you're just going
to take on h7 next then there's no real
great way to stop it if you try h5 or h6
i'm still going to just sack on that
square so i can even play queen here for
example
and rook takes h6 is a common and once
once rook takes h6 hits you're going to
be very very unhappy
let me put it that way like this
position just completely falls apart
so this is kind of what he's going for
basically just trying to kill
him on the king side so taking on f4 is
actually not so great
so he plays knight f6 but now he just
loses all sorts of time he gets g5 in
and f5 in
so grisha gets all these attacking moves
in at black's expense basically like
black just has to move the knight back
and forth
so this is why calculating those extra
lines playing g4 when it's a tempo move
really comes into play
because you're trying to
advance your attack with tempo as
quickly as you can
so when you try to play with like g4 f4
and you're doing it all with tempo you
just get so many extra moves
and getting extra moves in a chess game
is very very important
um so
uh already i think mvl's position is
very unpleasant but he's a very
resourceful guy and again
it's one of the things i always am i'm
always amazed by when you watch
these really top players play which is
that how difficult they are to beat
because
they will find every last resource
possible and they just do not
die very easily and mvl played some
amazing defense in so many games this
tournament
uh he got in a lot of bad positions
which is why he lost some games
particularly at the end his opening prep
didn't hold up but like
he defended so well even in his loss
against fabiano for example one of the
best games of the tournament in my
opinion
he defended amazingly well and i feel
like that's an ability that these guys
have whereas
you know gm's of around my level say who
are 200 points below
or so just like i'm not saying we can't
defend at all but we're
much worse defenders than these guys
like we would collapse far quicker
uh so at least the player like me is in
awe of how these guys defend and i think
even when you're going over the games
even look at how the losing player plays
and how they defend because so often
they'll defend
so tough and yeah the prep by sasha was
really good i'd say
it's funny i i put together a list of my
favorite candidates games or games i
found interesting that i wanted to go
over or maybe lecture on
and half of them were shoot games or
more than half like almost all of them
i just find his game so interesting and
so rich whether he wins or loses like so
many interesting games he plays
and his opening ideas also are very
varied and very interesting
so rick fd8 was what was played by
unveil here
and in this position honestly this was
the decision which uh
i recall steven was not as happy with
uh and i kind of understood a little bit
more because to me it was more
positional
but i'm curious what you guys would play
here so the question honestly for me is
do you try to play knight g3 and crack
at that knight
or do you play f6
what do you guys think
yeah i don't know it's kind of different
like for me
like the main reason that steven kind of
wanted to
not play f6 was because like say you
have this position so believe it or not
so we looked at knight f4 but the basic
idea is that
in this kind of position right and say
you bring your pieces over
so there's this defensive technique
where let's say this happens just for
the heck of it right
there's this defensive technique where
you play h5
and then move the bishop say somewhere
and then here and you try to create your
kink here
and the whole point is that now you're
targeting a checkmate but if white can
play takes and opening up your king this
way you're probably still toast
something like this knight takes e4 is
probably good here you've probably many
winning moves right this is a bad
example
but basically because of that structure
you're doing pretty well
um yeah knight f4 is actually a really
crazy idea and then
like you can actually sack here and try
this which is actually quite
interesting the idea is if you try to
play bishop f8 or something i play rock
h1 and you're just gonna get mated
uh so you have to try something like
king here but i thought king e8 was at
least a try
to be fair though this is very sketchy
and
after either pawn takes or queen takes
it looks very very close to being busted
so yeah he killed the bishop uh which i
again i thought was very normal but one
of the points steven made which i
thought made a lot of sense here
is that in lines where this happens he
at least has some h5 options with the
idea that after g takes h king h7
there's no more f takes g and because of
this
white's more stopped up this is a
position where black's actually
defending very well because there's no
clear open line to your king it's one of
those positions where you're cursing the
fact you have a pawn here
so this is kind of a common defensive
technique the reason i think it wasn't
played in the game is because of exactly
how
grisha crashed through in the game and
i'll show you what i mean
he played d5 and by the way this is why
f6 doesn't kill the bishop that much
because this does get the bishop out
but it definitely makes the king feel
very uncomfortable
so he takes and then knight takes g3 and
h5
so this was his whole idea in this
position by the way
uh because the thing is i did could
check with the computer briefly this is
one of the decisions where the computer
really disagrees horribly
i always check just because sometimes it
points out interesting things i miss
right
and this was one of the funny ones
because both stephen and i really like
griez's idea
computer just wants to take and then
play rook h1 and says you're just busted
because h7 is just going to kill you
i kind of believe it just because knight
e4 is coming the e pawn's very weak
um
and i don't know this position probably
is just very very good for white
um grishik played this which i think is
also good enough but it's a little bit
trickier
but this is his idea it looks as if his
attack is dead now
but the fact is it's just begun because
after rook c5 he plays rook h3
and after knight takes d5 he takes and
plays here
i think you guys see his idea
well i don't know if it was that clear
because i think that in this position
grishok very likely would have actually
played the same idea he played in the
game he wouldn't have taken he would
have played this move for example
or may or perhaps he would have played
this other rook instead
and you know what's coming right the
sacrifice on h5 and it's actually very
difficult to stop this sacrifice in the
long term
it's very very difficult because once
rook h5 happens your king is just so
dead
again i would say that's not a rule that
i would go by right it's like
keeping tension is again like a 60 40
proposition there are so many times
you're supposed to relieve it because f6
is such a good move to get in
there are times when you're not supposed
to and to give a general rule like that
is just really difficult
everything's dependent on the situation
and i would say though that here he
didn't really have to relieve the
tension right away
but it probably wasn't terrible to do so
either i think it was a matter of taste
more than anything else
in any case it wasn't so much about
relieving tension he wanted to fix
black's pawns this way
so h5 so he goes for queen e2
and here and then rook dh1
so the this is where a really really
interesting phase of the game starts
so he wants to play rookies h5 and i
remember looking at this
and thinking this game is almost over
rook takes h5's comment and he is toast
there is no way to stop that
so the question is how does he stop it
because mvl comes with some amazing
resources here that were actually quite
something
yeah again like there are different
situations i've definitely seen
sicilians though where playing g5 f6 is
just good
you know and i would say that especially
when you have players
of this level who are play every type of
position like gushing plays d4
alliance he plays e4 lines he's probably
thinking more like a d4 player than an
e4
player of basically gaining all that
space and then taking advantage of it
but again i think in this particular
situation the way he did it should win
right but leaving the pawn on f5 should
also win i really think it's a matter of
taste more than anything else like i
said
i thought f6 looked okay to me steven
really didn't like playing f6 he
probably wouldn't have but at the same
time we both agreed it should be good
enough to win
well bishop g7 the problem is i can just
take it like i don't have to mate you
right
like i can take a g7 and just be up a
piece so i i don't think
i i haven't sacrificed anything yet
right
yeah i mean i really am appreciating
this bishop on b2 it's such a good piece
but as we saw mvl could have maybe taken
advantage with that knight g4 type move
and that would have made grishak's life
much more difficult
even though probably it's still
objectively okay it's not so easy
but okay how does mvl defend put
yourself in mvl's shoes
incredible defender that he is how would
you try to defend as black here
it's possible but what do you do here
right
keep in mind after rookie after rook d1
i'm not obligated to take your rook
either right
black's upon up but i would say the pawn
up is kind of irrelevant for the time
being like
i see this a lot where where lower
players are like
like say i'm teaching someone who's i
don't know not new to the game but like
you know 1400 ish right and they're like
all right i'm up a pawn so i should just
try to trade off all the pieces and
the fact is that there are some
positions you should in some positions
you absolutely should not trade anything
if you have an attack you should try to
trade everything here yes black would
love to trade pieces because they don't
want to get mated
but at the same time an endgame with
your king like this if white
is able to win a pawn especially which
is very likely you're probably still
going to be dead
so it's kind of like it depends which
end game you get it depends on the
situation and you also need a way like
there are plenty of positions where it's
like
well if i trade queens i'm probably
winning but yeah but you're never going
to trade queens in this lifetime
so it's like yes black would love to
trade pieces that's you're absolutely
right
but it's not so easy to do how do you
actually accomplish it and keep in mind
that white's not going to want to allow
trades at all
i will say though that in this position
it's absolutely the right idea for black
you must want to trade pieces because
you're going to have problems so rook d2
looks like a nice defense right
but i think the issue with it is that
i'm you know i can actually just take
this pawn you're not actually
threatening my queen because of mate
so takes is always losing for the most
part you can play rook d1 check
but i would say that this end game is
actually really really bad for you
because now this king on a g8 is just
still terrible
i'm still ready to play queen h5 g6 and
the e5 pawn's probably just a goner
so what's really funny is even though
you've escaped quote unquote to the end
game this position is actually very bad
i think
uh because g6 is just gonna be way way
way too strong
let's say you play e4 here i probably
can just play g6 right away right
because if you try taking i play check
and i think you just get destroyed here
because my pawn's moving up i mean
you're still gonna get mated the end
game actually does not save you because
queens are still on the board
so i think that this would be an example
of why this is also
dead lost um
so even that position i think is quite
bad
mvl played a defense which is probably
quite a bit better
it's kind of amazing though right like
even you get to that end game you're
like all right i'm safe and then it's
like no
you're not even remotely safe it's kind
of cruel almost
is the way i would phrase it
like it's just cruel
so bishop b4 is possible but i still
don't see how it helps us in the rook h5
lens i think we still get mated there
so rook d2 has already been tried what
other moves do we have
so the movie play in the game was queen
d6
and this is quite resourceful because
now he's trying to play rook d one check
so rook takes h5 here the idea now is i
can actually take this way maybe or at
least try it because if queen takes i
have rook d1 check
so that's kind of the key thing that
you're putting more pieces on the d
file but grishook plays a very very
clever move here what do you guys think
white could try
very good king a2 just sidestep the rook
move
but okay mbl still wants it right he
plays rook d1 once again
rook d2 rook takes h5 you probably just
resign right
like you just don't have any resources
now
um you just get mated uh i saw bishop h6
mentioned i don't know which position
probably not here but it never really
saves you right i just keep taking stuff
so you probably have to try something
like rook d1 right
and now i play rook takes h5 which is
what was played
gtx h5 but this position was quite
amazing what grishook played looks very
good
but allows an amazing resource this part
of the game by the way is so difficult
um because this was something that i
analyzed with stephen afterwards and we
didn't come close to figuring this out
this was so complicated but i give you a
hint
grishok played rookie's h5 which looks
very strong
but nvl has an amazing resource to try
to counter it
uh and we'll get to that in a moment but
the winning move here is actually very
very subtle
so i'll show you what happened in the
game first he played rook takes h5 and
what is black's amazing resource that's
the first amazing thing to
to figure out because it's quite a
resource i will say
so again put yourself in mbl shoes for
the black pieces how do you save this
game you're about to get brutally
checkmated with queen h2
or some move like this
so bishop h6 i always take it it doesn't
really help you
rookie one check is kind of a cool idea
because if i take with the queen you can
play queen d1 but i think i can take
this way
because you can check me here but i go
back i don't think you actually do
anything
so i think this is kind of okay
yeah and queen d2 i want to say rook h1
should do it
is that true is this too much
maybe this is too much
but my idea is that if you take i play
check here and then
here oh no you have queen h6 now this
just doesn't work
in the in the line after something like
e4 sorry the line where i was thinking
this oops
was e4 and now i think i can do this
because my bishop's open so after
check here here you can't save the game
this way because
if takes takes here i give a check with
the bishop
and now queen g8 is a threat so i just
made you
so that's why against against e4 rook aj
check i think works after queen d2
um
after queen d2 what's what do i do here
there is a win that much i know
but what is it
i know it's here queen d2 what's the win
guys
all have this oh it's queen e4 of course
yeah we're threatening queen h7 mate
this just wins sorry yeah queen e4 very
good
yeah just drawing a mind block melt down
there
yeah so mvl's move was rook d4
which is absolutely amazing the idea is
that after
bishop takes d4 you have queen a3 check
and takes and now you have enough
resources to draw because you can't play
queen h2 yet because of rook d1 made
so you have to play rook back to h1 and
now it's sax and this is a perpetual
because you can't try to win because the
bishop can come out here the queen could
come down here so you have to just do
this and draw
so something like this is pretty good um
so rook d4 was kind of an amazing
resource the best move in this position
was rook h3
and the computer showed this to me i
didn't find this and i was like what
so here i guess like rookie one's like
the best try but it still loses or
something
but if you play if you play this move
the idea is that now you play rook two's
h5
and if you play mvl's resource you can
simply take it and go here
and you just win because the queen's on
e6 it's actually a worse square
because the queen can't go to a3 so
after it takes here you just lose
so the rook h3 though good luck finding
her cage three
but it does win for white it's
completely winning he played rectus h5
and now rook d4 should be good enough to
draw
mvl sorry grishook played rook here mvl
takes
place queen d5 hitting the rook he sacks
and this is the whole idea he sacks for
the rook and i think grishok must have
missed this
and here he should probably draw but
it's so difficult
the key is that he actually can't
capture the pawn on g5 because it gives
white too many ideas
rookie 8 is probably the best move and
the idea is that after here you can play
b6
and even though white has this extra
kickside pawn it's very difficult to use
it because you can never get in g6 so
easily
so once i get in this i can kind of play
like bishop c5 and just kind of chill
at some point if queen h6 always bishop
f8 i guess
or play maybe chill with a rook on e6 or
something like this and just kind of sit
and it's actually very very difficult
for white to ever break through here
but again this is very difficult to see
during a game
uh in the game he played rook takes g5
and now grishik played queen takes b7
check which is really sweet
the idea being that if you play rook
takes e5 i have
check on g2 and check on h2 forking
so he tried rook d2 and now i think
bishop f4 was maybe the easiest win he
played bishop c3 instead
queen check or queen fc8 here
bishop takes a five and one this way and
this was an amazing calculation because
at first i thought this
endgame should be kind of a draw or at
least close
the problem is this king is actually
really really terrible and it's very
difficult to actually get it in the game
so he tries to come around with king h7
but the problem he has here is that
after king d3
bishop c3 guarding the pawn king c4 so
the thread is king d5 you have to do
something about that
b4 there's no way to actually get the
king if the key could get here you'd
have a chance at drawing because this
bishop kind of
holds out the king from these two
squares
the problem is you can never get there
because if king d6 or some move like
this
you have the very very strong king b5
king a6
and now the problem is you can't
actually do that because i'm just going
to slowly come up with the board with my
pawn
and i think that it's just over more or
less
so i'm able to basically come up the
board with my pawn um
and that should do the trick so for
example if here here
so i'm ready to kind of come here if
you're not careful or something like
this and the point is if you ever go
back i just slide my king over to c6
and that's going to be way too good
because then my bishop just comes around
eventually lands here
and then i push
so something like this
um so in the game he tried bishop d6
but now he can play b5 and the whole
point is that after king d7 he plays
king d5
very important if you give him one more
move and gets the king to b7 something
like this
and plays this and this it's actually
very difficult to win
uh it's very difficult to actually get
your king in so something like this is
often
very very drawish believe it or not
so it's one tempo but it's enough he
plays king d5 and now the whole point is
that
you can't really play king c7 because
well first of all this move just wins
right
just trade bishops king in here
um but there's just nothing he can do he
plays here bishop d4
if bishop g3 you just play b6 there's
again no defense to this
so he tried bishop d8 and then b6 and
that was it
because again he can't play i think he
may have even resigned earlier but the
idea is that now this is a threat and
you have no moves
so you have to try this and i play king
here i'm ready to do this
you can try one last trick but this will
not work i'll just check
and give a check
and that should be it anyways um
this was a really complicated game i
hope i at least gave it some justice
it was hard to get through all of it and
the same thing with the italic game but
i hope you really enjoyed these games i
really liked
learning from grishok in this game and
also learning kind of from my own
mistakes but also
looking at some very interesting chess
so i hope you guys enjoyed it as well
and i will see you
uh the next youtube lecture i'm gonna
give i believe is on tuesday
for insane in the end game at the same
time 7 30. so
i will see you then uh thanks everyone
for tuning